today as i said we're here with jennifer
ocher the general atlantic professor at
stanford in the graduate school of
business who will be talking today with
steve clayton the vp of global public
affairs and the chief storyteller at
microsoft
among other things they're going to be
talking about steve's journey in
transforming the way that microsoft
communicates both internally and with
the world and with that we are going to
get started thank you for being here
both of you and take it away
thank you robin it's so wonderful to be
here
um
among a few classes that i teach at
stanford power of story is one and i
think um there's no
more popular guest
than steve clayton that we could have
here today so i'm really excited to talk
with you steve thank you for being here
um let's start with just the facts you
are among a couple of titles that you
have we'll talk a little bit about that
later you are also the chief storyteller
officer at microsoft so can you tell us
a story about how that role came to be
and how you became part of it
yeah well first of all thank you robin
and jennifer it's um it's great to be
here and just amazing to see you know
how many people um are excited to hear
about storytelling so i hope we can do
it justice uh from the stories here at
microsoft but i'll sort of tell you a
quick um
two-part story of how i ended up a at
microsoft and then b in this job of
storytelling uh because i always like to
start with the story
the fast version of the story is about
um well i joined microsoft in 97 uh but
i left university i think in 91 or 92
and i went to work for a company in the
uk i'm originally from the uk despite
this accent that sits mid-atlantic these
days
but i worked for a company in the uk
that many of you will know it was called
zenica back then it's now called
astrazeneca obviously one of the
producers of a covert vaccine but i
worked in the i.t department at zenica
straight out of university
and uh in that i.t department at zenica
we spent lots of time working with
microsoft we were one of the biggest
customers of microsoft and this is way
back 20 25 28 years ago or something
like that
and so i got to know lots of people at
microsoft incredibly well
and um so much so about two year three
years into the job at zeneca i get a
phone call and i'm in the office and i
pick up the phone and i said hi it's
steve and the person on the other end of
the phone says steve it's paul from
microsoft and he says listen well i'm
not really supposed to do this he says
but would you be interested in a job at
microsoft and i said well i'm you know
i'm flattered i would love to have a job
at microsoft he said great i'll put you
in touch with the hr team at microsoft
and we'll get you through the process so
i go through this very long interview
process multiple different you know
rounds of interviews and ultimately get
offered the job at microsoft and so i go
back to zenico on a monday morning i go
into my boss's office and i say hey i've
accepted a job at microsoft and i'm
going to be joining microsoft
and well actually what i should have
said earlier in the story is uh every
month a group of people from xenica from
the it department would go to visit
microsoft at the head office in a place
called reading in england and so that's
how i got to know the team at microsoft
very well so i walk into my boss's
office and i say hey i've accepted this
job at microsoft and you know my start
date is in a month's time and he says
you know we're sorry to lose you but
let's just work through this final
month's period and finish up your
projects here at zenica and so i had a
month left working at zenica and during
this month we had one of these regular
visits to the microsoft office in in
reading
and so i arrive at the microsoft office
we have a day of meetings meet with all
of the team at microsoft and then we
wrap up the day of meetings and as you
do you go to the pub for a few drinks
after the meetings because i like to say
that all good stories start or end in a
pub so i'm in the pub i'm with a friend
from zaneca and the door to the pub
opens it's this beautiful um country pub
it's called the bull in a place called
sonning if you ever find yourself in
that area the bullet sawning is a
fabulous pub on the banks of the river
thames the door to the pub opens i'm
stood at the bar with my colleague from
zenika who's also called steve
and in walks this guy called paul paul
had made the original phone call to ask
me to apply for the job but paul had not
been involved in the interview process
at all
and so he sees the two of us walk
straight up to the bar and stretches out
his hand in the classic handshake move
to the other steve and says
congratulations on the job and the other
steve looks at paul and looks at me and
says i think you mean him
and in that moment paul realized that he
had phoned the wrong steve originally
he'd meant to phone the other steve but
worse than that microsoft hired the
wrong steve and this is a genuine true
story literally microsoft hired the
wrong steve they were trying to hire
steve clark and they hired steve clayton
um anyway so paul and i decided that we
would keep this a secret for a while and
by a while we mean about 18 years so
about
four years ago our chief hr officer
invited me to come and speak to all of
the hr professionals at microsoft 1500
people in a giant you know hotel
ballroom here in seattle and i thought
this is it the best of the best of
microsoft hr team this is the time to
unload the wrong steve story and so i
told them that story
of how i got hired into microsoft so
that's the first very quick story the
second story about the chief storyteller
job i'll try and do even quicker is i
had been working in the uk for about um
probably 11 or 12 years and i'd started
to write a blog about the company
because i was very frustrated with the
public perception of microsoft and this
is in you know the early late 90s early
2000s
and the blog got quite popular it wasn't
my day job it was a hobby my day job was
selling and talking about microsoft
technology
and a couple of years into writing this
blog i got a phone call from a guy
called frank shaw and frank runs
communications for microsoft runs all of
pr and all of communications
phones me up one evening in london it
was a wet tuesday evening i remember it
vividly i picked up the phone again and
this time the voice said steve it's
frank shaw
and i knew who frank was and i thought
oh oh dear this is it this is the day
i'm going to lose my job i'm going to
get fired because of something i did on
my blog
and my voice went up a few octaves and i
sort of said well you know how can i
help you frank and he said well i think
i think it's how i can help you he said
i i think you should come to seattle and
do that as a full-time job that blogging
thing um so that's what i did just about
11 years ago moved to seattle and began
this journey as chief storyteller of
microsoft
okay so um for all of you who are
joining late one of the key insights
here is all good stories start and end
with a good pub or a good drink at many
many different types of puffs um tell us
a little bit more about your mandate so
you get to microsoft you have this
mandate um one of the things that i find
is so interesting is how you actually
build a skill um and and so kind of take
us through chapter by chapter what you
did
yeah well i
when i first showed up here it was um
the first i would say few months was a
little bit daunting because remember i i
don't i came from an i.t background my
profession my what i studied at
university was a classic sort of i.t
course so i didn't really have a
profession in journalism or writing or
communications but i did have a passion
for it and so when i showed up my job
was what we at least for the first few
years is what we call an individual
contributor so i was just it was just me
um and then i got to grow a team which
we can we can talk about hopefully um
but for the first
few years my job was really to be a
spokesperson and a blogger and a
so-called evangelist for the company
all around technology and innovation but
i had i really didn't have much of an
idea of how i would do that so what i
started to do in the first few weeks
here in seattle and we have a a huge
campus with about 55 000 employees
spread across this beautiful green
campus up here in seattle
and i just started to go around and
interview people and just talk to people
i knew or knew of and asked them if i
could have 30 minutes of their time and
just understand what they were working
on and then every person i spoke with at
the end of the interview i said to them
who would be five other people that you
would recommend i would go and talk to
and so within two months i conducted
about 45 or 50 interviews with just a
group of incredible talented people at
microsoft and all kinds of different
roles
and
and then um
i wrote a series of blog posts so we set
up a new blog we sort of closed my whole
blog down set up a new blog that was
called next at microsoft and we got
ready to launch uh this blog and i wrote
five launch blog posts all about these
interesting people that i'd met
and then i spoke to my manager at the
time uh and i said okay we're gonna
launch the blog next week and he said to
me great have you run all of these blog
posts past the pr team and if you run
them all past the legal department
and i said no i didn't realize i had to
do that and he said well you know you're
going to be speaking on behalf of the
company so you really ought to do that
and i thought this this isn't what i
signed up for and so i phoned a friend i
phoned my friend frank who'd basically
you know asked me to move me and my
family five thousand miles
and i remember going home actually the
night before and saying to my wife i
said you know i think i think we might
have to go back to the uk because i
think this job isn't what i thought it
was going to be
um but i found frank and i said listen i
would love to just chat with you about
some challenges i have and i sat down
with him in a pub unsurprisingly a place
called the attic
madison park
over a beer and i said listen
i the first one was called i'm going to
make a list of these steve the first one
was called the
pub
the bowling sonning
s-o-n-n-i-n-g this one is called the
attic in um in madison
for everyone keep going
okay so uh so i sit down with frank and
i basically said listen i love this job
you know i'm happy to be here but i have
this real challenge is i've written this
content and it's very much written in an
authentic in my voice and i want to
publish i said and i don't i didn't
realize i had to run this by the pr
department in the legal department and i
worry that that's going to water down
the message and take away the
authenticity
and he looked at me and he just said
steve just publish he said just go ahead
and publish he says i brought you here
to tell stories tell the stories and in
that moment and it puts the house up on
the back of my neck now he gave me this
permission to just say go and tell
stories on behalf of microsoft you know
what's and i always like to say you know
what's the worst that can happen i could
get fired um and i'll come back to that
it's a story i tell my team i have this
catchphrase i give them around that but
anyway so we started to i started to
build up this body of content and then
the next few steps in the journey
that was relatively successful so much
so that frank a few years later came
along and said hey i i think you should
take on a team and run our team that we
had a website that used to be called
newscenter which really was just a
vehicle for releasing press releases at
microsoft and he said you know you
should think about how do we want to
evolve newscenter and so we started to
change how we did deliver the news
and then there was this pivotal moment
of which i'm sure some people will
remember of when snowfall the story that
the new york times wrote um john branch
wrote this incredible 13 000 word story
about a tragic avalanche that happened
not far from seattle actually that
killed a number of skiers and the story
was incredible it won a pulitzer prize
but the way it was delivered on the web
and this is probably seven or eight
years ago now but it still stands the
test of time if you haven't seen it go
and take a look at snowfall and it's
delivery of a story digitally was
phenomenal and i remember again talking
to frank on that day albeit not in a pub
and we said this is it this is the
future of storytelling and actually this
is the game that we should get into is
telling our stories in this way not just
as a dry press release but as an
immersive
content with real
journalistic um skill sets applied to
the storytelling and so we started to
build this team we launched our own
there's another story about we created
our first
um owned story as we called it that was
called 88 acres about three or four
months after that that shamelessly
ripped off snowfall and we were we were
shameless about that
and then um that just began this journey
of um storytelling becoming a real
discipline and a profession at the
company and there are a few other
chapters but i'll pause there because
that's sort of the first couple of
chapters
great good good place to pause let me um
sprinkle in a couple of of comments um
from the audience one is from katya who
just you know she argues
sounds very similar to a brand
ambassador role you know how you might
think of chief storyteller um and then
so maybe a little comment about how you
think of bran versus story but also she
she was wondering about how do you make
sure to keep your voice so authentic to
microsoft's you were certainly empowered
at the beginning by frank but how do you
kind of maintain that as you build out
the team do you want to take one or both
of those
yeah i'll take both of them i think the
brand one it's a really good observation
is i
the work i do and increasingly the work
i've done over the last few years has
become more and more tied to brand and i
think it is about being a brand
ambassador
but being a brand ambassador genuinely
for the brand and for the company versus
a brand ambassador for the products of
the company and i think that those are
two distinctly different things and
neither of them are bad but all of the
work i've done really over the last um
10 years has been about building
uh brand awareness and being a brand
ambassador if you want to call it that a
chief storyteller brand ambassador for
the company so it's very much been about
and and that became in some ways an
easier job about seven six and a half
years ago we
uh we changed the mission statements of
microsoft we
um sachin nadella became our ceo about
seven years ago
seven and a half years ago and
relatively early into such as tenure we
changed the mission statement to be to
empower every person and every
organization on the planet to achieve
more
and what that gave us was as
storytellers it gave us this license to
say we can go and tell stories in
service of that mission which we didn't
really have before we'd had mission
statements as a company
for example the first mission statement
of microsoft back in 75 was to put a pc
on every desk and in every home which is
a noble mission
but it doesn't really give you a lot of
uh
license or cover for telling stories
about brand and about the impact a brand
has on the world whereas empower every
person and every organization on the
planet to achieve more gives you a huge
amount of landscape to go and tell
stories about the impact the company has
um and and didn't really require me to
go and talk about products not to say i
don't like our products but it's uh
hopefully that sort of answered that
question
yeah definitely and actually sid had a
related question to um katya's which is
can you talk a little bit about you know
as a brand ambassador as a you know
storyteller how do you walk that line
between you know what is truthful and
authentic
um to microsoft and um
but also kind of representing this
larger higher purpose
um and i think what they're getting at
is we're at a moment at time where you
know misinformation and you know kind of
making things look prettier than they
are
is something that seems to be something
that people are grappling with is that
how does that fit into your job or how
do you think about these kind of issues
between sort of truth versus
you know the stories that are being
shared internally um outside to the
world
i think um this might sound a bit right
but i think about it a lot and i don't
think about it because i think you know
i'm fortunate that i work at a company
where we've spent a lot of time
very intentionally over the last i would
say 15 years really thinking about trust
and how do we build trust and how do we
build trust with all audiences consumers
policy makers regulators and the the
truth is um ironically we haven't always
had that in the history of the company
but i would say that we are in a
position where
we do have that and that's it's not by
accident it's by putting a lot of energy
and work and effort into just being
truthful into being honest into
accepting mistakes into talking about
where we need to improve and to not sort
of hide in the facts from people you
know a great example recently was there
was a huge cyber attack um that became
known as solarwinds and microsoft uh you
know played a big part in that in both a
good way but also in a way where you
know we were we were attacked ourselves
from a cyber attack and what we could
have done is hidden that information and
not talked about it because people
generally don't want to talk about the
fact that they've been being hacked and
microsoft technically wasn't hacked i
won't bore you with the technical
details but we were incredibly public
about it because it was important that
people
got to hear about that the people
understood the impact of it companies
and individuals the people got to
protect themselves and so it's um i
think one of the things that i think
you're getting at in that question is
just around
how do you
uh i don't really think about it so much
as walking the line i think about it as
just being honest being authentic and
and telling the truth and then you never
will feel yourself on the tightrope i
haven't to walk that line um because you
can sort of go home at night and say you
know we told the truth we told the right
story and and we're not trying to dance
on some knife's edge
fantastic i want to go back to the
mandate and um and kind of you know the
chapters that unfolded one specific um
question
talk about how you built the team so for
example with some companies that i know
that build out story as a core capacity
you know they go from an individual
contributor to then having a writer and
then having um you know a filmmaker and
then like you know kind of like parse
that and in particular um
arun i think that's how you pronounce it
i'm not sure he asked um with the rise
of podcast you know if you had to go
back and do it over again right now if
you're in your position right now trying
to build out a team can you also talk
about the role of a podcast versus you
know script or blog yeah
yeah so the in terms of how we built out
the team there were a group of people
already on the team that i inherited
this new center team who all you know
came from an editorial background but
really i think one of the the pivotal
moments is when we decided to really get
into owned content and back to that
story i mentioned 88 acres the story
behind that you'll be pleased to know
started in a pub so there is a pub on
microsoft campus that's called boardwalk
um and i met uh i had a meet or there
was a sort of a social gathering a
boardwalk several years ago and i ran
into this guy rob and he said oh i've
got this great story for you steve and
it was all about he said you know it's
all about real estate and facilities at
microsoft
and i said come on rob i said real
estate facilities i said you know we're
talking about super cool technology here
and you want me to go and tell a story
about buildings and he said no i think
you should go and explore this story
and so i did i went and met this guy
called daryl smith who
basically managed our buildings and you
know ensure the power came on and
lighting came on and there was water to
the buildings and stuff like that and
daryl
true to robbie had this incredible story
about how our entire campus had been
digitized um and so i will get to the
answer to the question here i'm building
up to it uh so i went and met daryl and
it's like wow this is an incredible
story so we packaged up the story
my team and i uh and we took in our
media agency and we took it to three
very large media outlets that i won't
name but every one of them said no we're
not interested in this story because
there's no news here so we'll pass on it
so
that was the point we um we assigned one
of our writers at the time to say well
we're going to go and do this story
ourselves and we wrote this 3 000 word
story called 88 acres and we published
it
and within two days it was incredibly
successful by any measure it had quarter
of a million page views we didn't put
any paid media behind it it generated a
whole different story as it generated
within a week a 10 million dollar sales
pipeline from this story
and so that was the moment where we said
wow this is something we have to go and
invest in my boss frank and actually our
cmo at the time uh i still see our cmo
chris capacella said let's go and invest
in this so i began to hire um
journalists and editors and so i hired a
guy called michael wyan who was
previously the uh the managing editor of
msnbc.com he ran a hundred person
newsroom and he came to to run and built
a team and still runs a team that is our
our story telling our news centers if
you like evolution of our new census
team the short answer to the question i
guess is we began to hire people from
journalistic backgrounds because we
really started to think like and act
like journalists
but then we started to add different
skill sets to that so we added video
capability we started to think a lot
about photography both of which we
contracted in we didn't have us
full-time positions
but the real answer to the question i
think is this is that what we hired for
is and what i always hire for even in
you know my team now is i hire for
curiosity you want people who are
curious about the world people who are
going to walk down a busy high street
and notice the one thing that's out of
place and say huh why is that out of
place and they're going to go and
explore it and investigate it and figure
out why and so really what we hire for
and the team we built is the people who
are just passionately curious about the
world but also tend to have a great
background in in writing and then to the
question from maroon around podcasts
i i have a little bit of a
love hate view of podcast i love
podcasts i literally listened to two on
the way to work this morning i listened
to the daily and listen to the politico
podcast
but i have this view of corporate
podcasts i think are a lot more
difficult um and the reason is because
there are lots of really great podcasts
out in the world already and so i we
have a few podcasts at microsoft one of
which i'm a huge fan of our cto is a guy
called kevin scott and he has a podcast
called behind the tech and i think it's
fascinating because he brings a unique
point of view on that
the if i went back in time and said
would i do things differently would i do
a podcast i think the answer is maybe
but i probably wouldn't do a microsoft
podcast because
as much as i love this company and i
think we play an important role in the
world i'm just not sure that people wake
up in the morning and say
you know what i want i need a podcast
from microsoft
i think what they maybe do want or would
benefit from is hearing from voices at
microsoft in other podcasts whether
that's with cara swisher where you know
we uh our president brad smith did a
great podcast with her or um you know
when we show up on places like the daily
and so i love podcasts but i'm
i think they have to that has to be very
careful thoughts about corporate
podcasts
because to do them well and we did we
actually did try one a few years ago
on my team that was called um
uh adult future and it's still out there
and it's still a great podcast but we
put a lot of money into it did we get
the roi i'm not sure we did because it
it hasn't existed and continued
right did you say um
dark what was it called
dot future dot future
yeah if you go to microsoft.com forward
slash podcast it sits on that webpage
okay now steve if you titled that
all good stories
start and end with a good pub and here
are the list of our pubs which robin by
the way is pulling together and i think
linking
this morning's just paid for itself all
right so um talk a little bit we got a
great question about how the story has
evolved you know you've started to take
us through the chapters you know
building out the team etc when you got
to microsoft um do you want to talk a
little bit about how the story has
evolved especially aligned with this
higher purpose that's also evolved since
satya has taken over
yeah i think if i look at all of the
work i've done i would say the work that
i'm most proud of and has been the most
interesting from a storytelling point of
view has been the last six or seven
years
around a lot of internal storytelling
actually at the company because satya
nadella became ceo i think february 4th
2014 so seven and a bit years ago now
and i i was involved in telling the
story around that even satchel's
announcement we did in a very different
way
um the way that you would normally do
something like that around announcing a
ceo of a you know a
fortune i'll call it a fortune 5 company
let me put it that way is that you would
write a press release and you would send
it across the wires to ap and bloomberg
and reuters and then you would sit back
and you would feel the set of questions
from the media and we said we're not
going to do that we are going to create
a website which we did at the time
microsoft.com ceo it was this beautiful
website it had a video of steve ballmer
or al going ceo he had a video bill
gates it had a video of john thompson
our then sherman and a video of sacha
the video of sacha was a walk and talk
interview with me that i'd shot with him
three days before we announced him and
it was this three minute three to four
minute great discussion of um instead of
the traditional let's sit in two chairs
and have two gentlemen talk to each
other we did this walk and talk thing
anyway we basically announced the ceo in
a way that nobody has ever done so much
so that the financial times wrote a
story and said microsoft is doing our
job for us and we wish they wouldn't
and that began this journey of us really
thinking about how storytelling can help
to drive culture change at the company
uh about a few months into satch's
tenure ceo we created what we call the
set of cultural attributes of the
company and i'll come back to those and
then we created this new mission
statement
and then a small group at the company in
the ceo's office in communications with
with my team and my boss and a few folks
in our hr team really got together and
became this what we called a culture
cabinet
who worked to say how are we going to
use storytelling and communications in a
in a not nefarious way in a very obvious
way to change the culture of this
company and so as an example i brought
some props today one of the first things
that we wanted to
satura was very keen to change was shift
this culture to what um you know as many
of you will i'm sure know intimately
carol dweck carol dweck's book mindset
has been like
almost the foundation of the culture
change at microsoft so for folks who
don't know carol dweck her book on
mindset is phenomenal
um so we wanted to launch this idea of
growth mindset to microsoft where
frankly you know we didn't have a growth
mindset and we said well how are we
going to do this with an audience that
is going to be very cynical about this
type of stuff
and so we sent emails on it we did lots
of different things but one thing we did
as an example so this is that i'm
drinking out of this morning this is the
standard microsoft coffee cup
um that you get in little coffee areas
across the campus so this a few of us
were stood in the coffee area one day
looking at this coffee cup and thinking
about this challenge of growth mindset
and how do we communicate it
and i had this realization that this is
the most unused billboard at microsoft
at least when we came into the office
hundreds of thousands of these things
were used on a weekly basis
and so we took a set of quotes from what
we called luminaries and we created a
set of custom coffee cups and i brought
a few so this is our albert einstein
coffee cup and it has a quote from
einstein on i have no special talent i'm
only passionately curious and we had one
from sir ken robinson we had i've got a
whole load of them here from mahatma
gandhi from coco chanel
and we put these coffee cups out into
the world and i know this sounds
ridiculous but it was we were constantly
thinking about what are tools and
techniques and ways that we can capture
people's attention
because back to storytelling and why i
think it's important storytelling i
think has become more important over the
last few years because people have
realized that our attention is under
attack
by data by information by billboards by
websites by radio by television by email
by alert by text messages
and i believe passionately
that that is why storytelling has been
on the rise because people have realized
that storytelling is what sticks with
people and so we started to explore all
of these different ways to tell stories
through physical devices like coffee
cups through
physical things that we put on our
buildings through
cam it rains a lot here in seattle so we
painted some of our sidewalks with
messages about culture change and they
only became apparent when it rained in
seattle the messages literally appeared
on the sidewalk when it rained so we
just started to explore all kinds of
different ways to do cultural
storytelling at the company
and i suppose the fast forward seven
years on
has the culture changed at microsoft
dramatically absolutely dramatically and
in fact the people who are joining
microsoft we interview people and we and
of people um i should put it this way 25
percent of people who are joining
microsoft are people right now or people
who are returning to microsoft and when
we interview people and ask them about
that when they rejoin and we say why are
you rejoining the company almost
universally they say because the culture
has changed so dramatically that it's a
company i now want to be back at
oh i love that sentence by the way we
have to get back to a couple signature
quotes of yours but i want to turn to
roi um uh return on investment we got a
question oh my goodness by the way we
have a ton of questions they're just
flooding in so i'm going to be sort of
selected here john asks
how do you connect stories with roi so
you mentioned for before that um you
know a story capacity led to 10 million
dollars in a sales pipeline so how do we
trans so i guess this is a two-part
question talk about roi of story and
then also when you think of small and
mid-sized um firms any kind of tips and
tricks to think about um you know how to
really invest in story in order and and
to prove out what is the roi in that
case versus you know a large company
yep
yeah back to that 10 million i sort of
just dropped that in there um that was
that does not happen very often i'll put
it that way we got very very lucky with
our first story i mean maybe lucky's a
bit unfair because it was a great story
but i'll i'll explain that a little bit
um is that we created this story three
thousand words
uh spread across five chapters all about
this real estate project
and
um we launched the story on a tuesday
afternoon and by the friday evening
daryl the hero of our story which we
should also come back to that of heroes
and stories and people
uh
daryl phoned me up at home on friday
night and remember daryl runs buildings
at microsoft he's not a sales guy and he
said steve i'm you know the i've just
been blown away by the response to the
story and i said well that's great daryl
you know tell me more and he said well
you know this funny thing happened the
day after the story ran he said i got
what i thought was a prank phone call
uh somebody had phoned the microsoft
switchboard because they didn't have
daryl's number and they said can you put
me through to daryl smith and the
switchboard said who's calling and they
said it's the office of the governor of
the state of tennessee and so this the
office of the governor of tennessee
makes their way through to daryl and
they said um hey daryl we saw that story
you published yesterday and we would
like to buy that we'd like to buy 88
acres for uh for the for the buildings
that we run in in the state offices and
daryl was a bit confused because he said
well it's not a product it's just it's a
pro it's a microsoft project that we
just we have this internal project and
the code name of the project was 88
acres
and they literally phoned up and said we
want to buy that that exact thing you've
done at microsoft please can we buy it
that is now actually a product at
microsoft it's called city next that we
sell to cities around the world to help
them digitally instrument the buildings
in cities
but that was one of five or six phone
calls that daryl got he got a very large
auto manufacturer in germany phoned him
a very large chocolate company in
switzerland phoned him and literally by
the end of the week he had essentially a
10 million dollar sales pipeline so when
i told my boss and i told her cmo about
this you know they they didn't have any
questions around the roi they just said
oh this storytelling stuff really works
let's do more of it
again i will say we sort of we uh we it
was a bolt of lightning that first story
because we've not done many others that
have been built a 10 million dollar
sales pipeline but the reason i tell you
all of that
is a month or so later i went back to
that story and i tried to figure out
what was it
that
that made people take that action to say
i'm going to read this story and now i'm
going to phone the company and try and
buy this thing
and it's really interesting in 3 000
words of that story there is a single
sentence what only one sentence that
mentions product
and i say that to people because you
don't need to bang people over the head
with your product to get them to buy
your product
and you know people had literally read
this and said i don't care what it is i
want to buy it because they bought the
story they bought daryl's journey and so
that i
six or seven years on i keep coming back
to and saying to people you know let's
just let's be careful about the
difference between marketing and
advertising which are two very important
professions that we have a lot of people
who work on microsoft and this
discipline of storytelling and they're
connected but to me they're slightly
different um so that's one sort of story
around roi
a couple of other things in roi there
are some very obvious metrics around you
know you can look at page views and you
could do things like that and this again
might sound right i will say the biggest
measure that we have of return on
investment is do the team go home at the
end of the day or the end of the week
feeling proud about the stories that
they wrote
um and i mean that very genuinely
genuinely and sincerely is that if we
feel proud about the things that we're
writing and putting out into the world
then it gets back to the question we had
much earlier on around are we being
great brand ambassadors for our company
through our storytelling
so then the next piece connected to that
is we do do brand measurements of the
company and we say you know where does
microsoft a couple of times a year we'll
measure with different audiences how the
brand is perceived and we don't directly
connect that
back to stories we could try but there
are so many things that influence
people's view of the brand that it would
be a difficult job to do
but we sort of take it implicitly that
some of the stories that we're telling
help with that brand and you know the
brand reputation of the company has been
on the rise for for many years now and
then the final remind me the final part
of that question oh around small and
medium
businesses any advice
my advice really this may sound very
simple is just figure out what your
story is like really truly what your
story is and this back to microsoft's
mission statement
i think we were in the wilderness for a
little bit and this is one of the
world's biggest companies right with a
lot of a lot of money and a lot of
markets and expertise a lot of
professions
but our story we sort of lost our way a
little bit around who we were we'd
achieve this piece a pc on a on every
home and every desk five years ten years
after that first mission statement
and then we'd have this period of not
really knowing what our mission
statement was we had a few but i think
if you ask people at the company they'll
be like well i'm not really sure if i
can remember the mission statement
now i'm gonna see if i have another prop
around here
something that we did
i convinced our teams to do a few months
after we coined this mission statement
so this is my badge from microsoft my
corporate badge we redesigned it made it
a bit more modern but then we put the
mission statement on the back of the
badge
um
because we want people to see it every
day and we want people to believe it and
we want people to
to live that mission statement and
that that honestly is my single best
piece of advice i can give any business
of any size is really figure out who you
are and what your story is and what your
place on the planet is
and then just be absolutely relentless
relentless about telling that story um
and if i give you a very quick final
anecdote on that one of the things
working with our ceo for these last six
or seven years the thing that i
am perhaps most impressed about
with him at least with storytelling his
capacity for repetition is phenomenal
and it's it's arguably the most
important thing in storytelling is we we
sometimes give up too quickly on telling
a story
that a couple things i wanted to go a
little deeper on and grab some questions
too you know in our class we talk a lot
about people want to be valued members
of a winning team
on an inspired mission so you got the
the new mission statement that inspired
mission um you know re revised um and
updated i think microsoft has just done
a really good job of making people feel
valued even your cup story is in some
ways a glimmer into like you know
actually making people feel at least
valued in the sense that you're thinking
you know thoughtfully designing around
them winning what is winning and you've
talked a little bit about sort of good
you know measures of of
you know of high performance um i think
so well and then last is you know they
need to feel like they're part of a team
and so i like some of the the ways that
you've actually structured your insights
around props and quotes and stories and
what satya has done and this you know
ability to you know be very tight
on um you know the mission and the story
i think that really backs that up
i think um another question that
alexandra mentioned was you know tell us
the elements of a good story
you've dropped in a few implicitly i
don't know if you've noticed um
steve you know brings in little details
that put people in the room so when
you're sharing a story even if there's
no prop there you kind of feel like
you're part of it like you're in that
pub or the addict or you know in madison
etc with him the thing that we do steve
is we talk about four four elements and
i'd love to see if you have other ones
that
that that also define a good story it
has a single focus goal so
you know it there's a reason you're
working that story and honing that story
and making it sparse and tight and
compelling and you know human-centric
daryl centric um it grabs attention so
it feels fresh
it's engaging authentically so people
often think that stories are these
manufactured things but when it backs up
with data then you get that authenticity
that's built in multiple dimensions and
modalities and then last is people know
how to think or feel or do
um
something differently after they heard
that story so they are unable to take
action and a lot of this is is built
into our book called the dragonfly
effect which is now quite old but those
four principles really stand up you know
what's the goal how are you grabbing
attention are you engaging authentically
and are you enabling action how do you
think about what a good story is
i think um i love all of those i think
they're you know they're they're very
much aligned with how we think and how i
think about stories uh i think the
single most important one and
i love how you sort of capture that i
drop things in the single most important
one is always people
uh and it's just you know great stories
don't happen without people or a person
being at the center of a story a person
being affected and if i look back six or
seven years ago lots of the so-called
storytelling we did it really wasn't the
stories in the truest sense because it
was much more
about us and about our products and even
some of the early storytelling i did
even though it was about people it was
about people at microsoft and we really
changed that and it's very rare now if
you go to news.microsoft.com
which is the website that the team built
called microsoft stories
um
all of those stories almost every single
one i would say if you looked at it
today i haven't looked at it this
morning but i will bet they're about
people who are being affected in a
positive way by microsoft's technologies
uh and services and products and and
things that we work on so it's always
about people but um
we have a book too and so
this is a book that a group of us that
microsoft created about two years ago
and it's called once upon a time the art
and craft of storytelling and i'm happy
to share it with everybody it's on it's
on my linkedin page um it's called we
call it the five ps and so when you go
inside uh it talks about people place
pictures personal and platform and i i
sort of chronicled this book over the
last few months on my linkedin pages if
people want more detail
um and this doesn't capture everything
about storytelling because i think some
of the things that you talked about
jennifer are not really in here around
you know what is the call to action what
is their authenticity um
but in terms of the craft of
storytelling
if you think about some of the stories
i've told the one about daryl it very
much was about a person and i tried to
put him in a place and then when you
take a look at the ada daga story you'll
see that it's it's you know has very uh
compelling pictures to support that and
then when we think about platform you
know back to the question around podcast
we think a lot about what is the right
platform to reach the audience that
we're trying to get to
um so those are the five things that we
really think about i
maybe another way to answer the question
and this does go back to i think arun's
question earlier around podcast a little
is if i could do something differently
over the last six or seven years that
we've done storytelling
i would have invested more and earlier
in photography um partly because i'm a
i'm a sort of shameless photography geek
i'm a terrible photographer but i love
photography
but that old ad age of a picture tells a
thousand words i think is even more true
in the world that we currently live in i
like to say a picture tells 10 000 words
because we are a
just as a species right we consume
visual information so much faster than
written information like
forget the metrics but at least 10 times
as fast
and there is a reason right why websites
like instagram and pinterest are so
popular because we like to visually
consume information we like to visually
share information that's not to say that
i want to get rid of the written word
because i think it's incredibly
important and impactful and powerful as
a way to deliver stories but i think a
lot of my team thinks a lot about how do
we deliver
stories in a visual way very quickly and
we've had the great pleasure to work
with a number of amazing photographers
over the last few years to help us do
that and some of the stories we've told
great um we have about 15 minutes left
and so what i want to do in those 15
minutes i want to make sure we get a
little bit more into story banking which
i find to be so important and in
particular also really interested in
your signature quotes and satyas that
that that actually launch a story or
that allow people to understand how you
lead and what you believe so that's two
topics i'd really like to get to
um and then i love to be able to uh ask
a question there's a couple of questions
in the in the field about global
storytelling like how do we think about
stories that resonate globally and then
i want to end
with um
a lightning round so for those of you
who are listening if you have a question
for steve that you think could be a
lightning round just pop it into the q a
and i'll pull it out and i'll give you
an example of what a lightning round is
we do this in our class as well at the
end we save just like 60 seconds and
just fire at you steve fast questions
like you know
hot pockets or pizza i'm just kidding
like we weren't we went actually that
but um
pizza
what would you describe um what's one
word that you would use to describe the
culture of microsoft you don't need to
ask this now but i'm just giving you a
sense like fire out questions with one
word answers
um so if you are in the chat feel free
to
think of lightning round questions where
steve just answers one word to tackle
your question so let's let's dive into
story banking this is one reason i
originally reached out to you which is
you know stories can be such a strategic
asset for a company and
is often not not leveraged um
and my dad and i actually have an
article called what is your your
signature story and we define them as
intriguing authentic involving stories
that have a strategic
mission you know internally or
externally can you talk a little bit
about the process of story banking
and um and then also you know how this
relates to you personally or satya as a
leader
yeah i would say on story banking it um
i'm going to try and keep my answers
shorter because we're going to get
through a lot here in 50 minutes is
story banking i think about goes back to
this idea of having people who are
curious and i think if you hire people
who are curious then you almost build a
natural story bank with the culture
storytelling we did build a literal
story bank where we said hey these five
cultural attributes we have as a company
we want to go out and search for and
almost in an investigative journalist
style we went out and said hey let's go
and get stories that help to illuminate
the story of one microsoft or let's go
and find stories that illuminate how
diverse and inclusive we are as a
company or let's find stories that are
excuse me employees of the company
demonstrated a growth mindset and we
started to catalog them unsurprisingly
we put them in an excel spreadsheet you
know the world's uh most overused
database
um and that's how we sort of catalogued
our stories but what that allowed us to
do is in key moments um often which were
such a keynote speeches outside of the
company sometimes inside of the company
we're able to go back to that story bank
and say hey we want to close this
this speech with an emotive impactful
story around um one microsoft or around
growth mindset and we were able to find
them very quickly and put those stories
into action
and then
um i'm tempted to go and grab another
prop that's somewhere in my office here
but
because it goes back to my last point
around photography i think you know the
most impactful story i've ever been
involved in at the company was with
satya and it was about six years ago and
we went to
a village called nanyuki in kenya
to tell a story that was around how
microsoft technology was being used to
connect 30 000 citizens of kenya who
were not connected to the internet and
literally
quite literally changed people's lives
and there's a whole bunch of stories i
can tell you there
but part of the reason we told that
story was we used it as the backdrop to
talk about the mission statements of the
company so back to that mission
statement have empowered every person
and every organization on the planet to
achieve more when you have your ceo
stood in a field with the principal of a
you know a very
small and basic school in the middle of
kenya with one of their students
and you say you know this is us living
our mission
and we created a set of iconic
photography around it and it became yeah
literally the the most amazing story
i've ever had the chance to work on
answer one quick question because you
mentioned a few times sort of catch
phrases the phrase that this point
around
curiosity uh
the phrase that if you ask my team
what's he known for saying they would
probably say this they would say he's
known for saying at least once a year he
will say this
if you're not trying something at least
once a year that almost gets you fired
then you're not trying hard enough
and i say that
fairly regularly to my team and i do it
not because i'm trying to get people
fired but because what that what i try
to do with that is institute a culture
that says i'm encouraging you to take
risks and i think if other people looked
at my teams over the last few years they
would i think i hope one of the things
they would say is these are teams that
have consistently taken risks they've
tried things differently they've done
things differently they haven't always
succeeded but i think a big uh part of
the culture that we've created and that
creates great stories is a risk-taking
culture
fantastic talk a little bit about global
how do you think about you know these
stories and what you're doing more
generally in a way that resonates from a
global perspective
we think about global alarm because we
are a global company and i think we
we continue to look for ways to bring
it's far too easy for us to tell stories
of everything that we're doing in the us
because it's a big country and we're
doing a lot and we you know it's um it's
home to
most of the world's
largest media companies that we work
with in new york times or the wall
street journal or places where we will
tell
stories on behalf of the company
but the reality is you know a lot of the
if i think about the keynotes i'll come
back to that the keynotes that i've been
involved in over the last seven or eight
years with saturn other execs of the
company we've been very intentional
about bringing in stories from around
the world to say here is how we are
bringing connectivity to 30 000 people
in kenya or here is how we're helping a
farmer and a small village in india be
able to get better crop yields and to be
more economical economically successful
or here is how we're helping a uh you
know a small medical company in the uk
do better radiology or a story i read
last night which is possibly the best
headline i've seen all year from our
team in australia that is how they're
using ai and low earth orbit low earth
orbiting satellites to be able to track
um herds of wild cattle across you know
the vast landscape of australia and it's
just so we we focus a lot on how do we
bring in global stories um
and almost over focus on it because at
times it can be too easy to tell local
and domestic stories
um fantastic um before we go into
lightning round where i'm going to take
some of the questions some of them are
dense but i'm going to try and move them
into one word answers
um
and i'd like i'd like to see you know if
you could just summarize if there are
three things that people attending this
session
need to know about how to get started
what would be those three things
my first one is back to your quotes i
came up with this one recently and
the most important thing is read widely
and share generously there's one thing
i've learned a lot over the last few
years it's just
in particular in the divisive
world we live in right now being very
intentional about reading widely and
then
sharing generously and sure and
intentionally so that would be one
the second would be you know
somewhat connected to that is just
staying curious you know just continue
to find ways to cultivate your curiosity
um you know go off the beaten path a
little bit read things that are or
explore things or watch things that
maybe you wouldn't wouldn't normally
watch
um so those are two and i've got it on
my feet come up with a third
um i suppose the third is really just be
prepared to take risks you know i would
say i gave this ted talk back in my
hometown of liverpool about five years
ago
and it was ultimately a talk although
there were about 500 people in the
audience but ultimately it was a talk to
my 13 year old nephew who had shown up
and was in the audience and basically
what i did is 18 minutes of career
advice to my nephew who was you know
about to embark upon secondary education
in the uk
and ultimately what i delivered in that
talk is my entire career has been
peppered with taking risks calculated
risks to say do i take this job at
microsoft do i take this job in seattle
do i decide that i'm going to go and
talk to my boss and say i you know i've
taken the wrong job i want to move back
and all along the way it's been about
um smart risks and so i just encourage
people to um
you know to take take good risks because
that
i have this very deeply held belief that
risks is being taking risks is the key
to being creative and innovative
um so inspiring and um and helpful um i
do want to mention that you have a new
role and maybe uh again before lightning
round you can just mention the role and
what your jurisdiction is so that the
audience can really see the full
transformation of not just the evolution
of story at microsoft but but also of
your role
yeah the very quick version is my new
role is uh which i started about two
months ago is vice president of global
public affairs so i sit technically
within our legal department
which means i get to work on you know
learn lots of new interests in language
around law and
legality and litigation and anti-trust
and competition and contract law and all
of that kind of stuff
but that part of the company also is
home to some of the most fertile
opportunities for storytelling as an
example you know we're doing a ton of
work as a company around sustainability
and how we can both
as a company contribute to you know
reducing the carbon in the atmosphere
but how we can create technology that
can help others do that we're doing lots
of work around racial equity we're doing
a lot of work around things like you
know advocating for for dreamers we're
doing lots of work around bridge in the
digital divide lots of work around how
do we reskill a population to get new
jobs for the 21st and 22nd century and
so all of those things are just
an evolution of
where i've been you know
over the last i would say 15 years
frankly which is telling stories about
microsoft i i love our products i will
tell you that but the thing i love more
than anything is i say to another thing
i say to my teams is you know lots of
people at the company their job is to
sell microsoft products the job of my
teams and i think of my job is to sell
microsoft and i don't mean sell in a
transactional way but really to be this
advocate and as somebody said earlier on
this brand ambassador and now i'm in a
place where i've got an even richer
collection of stories to go and tell
about the impact this company has on the
world
great
are you ready for lightning round
let's do it all right
um
which important quality of yours landed
you at microsoft and you can't say steve
you can't say your name
which important quality landed me here i
would say curiosity
i knew you'd say that um if you had to
condense the co or capture the culture
of microsoft in one word what would it
be
learning
what do you think is more important how
you say it or what you say in the story
how you say it
how many years to go through for a
complete complete switch of culture that
that's been done at microsoft
uh the answer is it's a never-ending
journey
um favorite social media
instagram
always a happy ending in our stories
or no no
um if you could go back and change one
something about the way you told a story
at microsoft what would it be
nothing no regrets
oh no regrets there's like another
chapter of a good book
um how to store how do different stories
in a company connect for success
so i guess they're looking for a verb
how do different stories connect for
success um
like i would say probably
serendipitously
sarah oh i like that i was gonna say
like emotionally like you know that like
if you think about you know i often talk
about you've got a person and you've got
a story and and the resonance of it is
like what exists in between um which has
a lot to do with you know personal
connection all right one word difference
between microsoft and apple from your
vantage point
uh a we don't have the letter a in our
company name
um and a one word representation of
microsoft as a as a brand
from your vantage point
so not culture but
but what it really represents
empowering
this has been amazing um we have like 30
seconds to spare and robin i couldn't be
more thankful for you and all of our
audience members for being so engaging i
think we had over a hundred questions
and we were firing at them um to steve
and steve you were just so insightful
and and and practical and inspiring so
thank you
thank you it was great fun
all of those things thank you to you
both it was it was so much fun sometimes
in the background i'm having to do a lot
of different things but i really got to
focus and it was it was very insightful
and very fun thank you thank you to
everyone who joined us because as
jennifer said it's all those questions
and the back and forth that really feels
like a live conversation because it's
about the people right steve it's about
the people that's it it's all about the
people that's what makes it so great
thanks for joining us today there will
be a recording link sent out and thanks
everybody we're signing off from
stanford
bye everybody
you